morning to order the criminal justice
now good
and public safety committee before we
begin representative
marston do you wish to lead us in the
pledge of allegiance
at this time we will
we now open the public hearing on house
bill
1027.
this time i'll recognize
representative baxter
to introduce house bill 1027
just let me know when you're ready
the floor is yours
well thank you representative abbas for
having me
um i'm here to talk about my bill hb
1027.
we live in a world that has been widely
impacted by covet 19 since february
2020 every person in the united states
has been impacted by the virus
whether it be through infection directly
or infection of their loved ones or
through government impact on their lives
in an attempt to stop the spread
for a significant amount of time
treatments and preventative measures
have been well known to the general
public
people are aware of the risks and
dangers of the virus and have the
freedom to make their own decisions and
how to best mitigate those risks
again for almost
two years we've been living through this
pandemic
laws must be made through the regular
legislative process
unconstitutional vaccine mandates are
coercing people into medical decisions
right here in new hampshire
one of the saddest things as a
legislator has been
calls from mothers
who are in tears
because they are choosing between taking
a vaccine they don't believe in
or putting food on the table for their
child
our healthcare workers that were hailed
as heroes
not that long ago
are now sadly being fired
if they don't take the vaccine
again right here in new hampshire
people are asking
how are we standing up
for our health care heroes
and let me be clear
politicians and bureaucrats that violate
our medical freedom by enforcing
unconstitutional and unlawful mandates
should go to prison
the legislative process is sacred
president joe biden is not a king
and the executive departments cannot
subvert the legislative process when it
is convenient
it is up to individual
state legislatures
and the united states congress to enact
legislation that impacts the citizens
executive orders written by the
current administration have given the
authority to osha to require employees
to force medical interventions on their
employees
it is well within the authority of the
general court to protect its
constituents
from overreach of federal executive
power
this bill aims to check the power of the
federal government and to defend the
people of our state from
unconstitutional
executive actions and decrees
that encroach
on their ability to conduct business
freely
this bill protects the right of private
businesses to make their own decisions
and what they require of their employees
and frees them from being shackled by
executive overreach
we are at a tipping point
the rights of the people of the state of
new hampshire need to be safeguarded by
this body
the federal government through a
grotesque amount of executive overreach
has overstepped its constitutional
authority
by directly disrupting the ability of
the people of new hampshire to conduct
business as a free people at this point
i'm happy to take any questions about hb
1027 thank you
thank you the representative is excused
representative walls you're recognized
thank you mr chairman representative
baxter you have a copy of your prepared
statement for the record
i'd be happy to give you one thank you
thank you representative you're excused
at this time that the chair recognizes
representative ukela
thank you mr chair
as this bill states
the legislative process is a core
process of our democracy
and
a lot of people may think of
um
treason as helping a foreign state
but in fact
not only is it helping a foreign state
but undermining the core of our actual
state
and
there are some people
who wish to subvert
that core aspect of the legislative
process
in our country
and that
should be taken with the most utmost
of seriousness
the
use of
coven 19
this far into a pandemic
is not a
legitimate claim of emergency the claim
of emergencies that
that go around our legislative process
are used
so that in a short amount of time that
people can react to
changing circumstance but two years into
a pandemic the legislature has ample
time
to
assess
and
respond
legislatively and so going around that
legislative process
is now
unwarranted
and that is why
uses
of whether it be
the osha mandate or something that
someone comes up tomorrow or the next
day
claims of emergency
and giving emergency power for new
rules and laws
under
that doesn't go through the normal
hearing process
and
being heard by the general public and
having a common period and all of those
normal things that a legislative process
has
should be frowned upon
and anyone
that passes such
uh
a rule or regulation
should be held accountable
and anyone that enforces any such rule
or regulation should be held accountable
that's all i have to say thank you very
much
thank you representative you're excused
next we call russman chester
thank you committee chair thank you
for hearing me today
the name is russian r-u-s-s-a-n last
name's chester born and bred in new
england new hampshire born here in
concord new hampshire
a long time ago
i used to be a very proud citizen of new
hampshire since becoming involved since
because of covet 19
that
image has been tarnished a little bit
um i became actively involved in the
this process
in the end of 2021 beginning of 2022
and i was actually
appalled with the way
people are being discriminated against
because of this pandemic
not only in our communities but right
here in our legislative body
this bill would hold those people
responsible and accountable
at every level and it needs to be done i
was in a senate hearing yesterday and um
one of the senators who spoke
actually it might have been a
representative hearing but he said the
bottom line is is that
we don't want to approve this because we
want everyone vaccinated that's not
appropriate that is not appropriate for
someone to take that kind of a stand
he's representing the people of new
hampshire not everyone in new hampshire
wants this vaccine not everyone in new
hampshire believes in this vaccine not
everyone in new hampshire trusts our
federal government or even our state
government at this point
i'm here today to support this bill
it's a good start
i'm not a proponent for more laws i like
less laws unfortunately i feel it's the
responsibility of this legislative body
to rise up against a tyrannical
government that's at the federal level
and i feel that it's not a partisan
issue it is actually a state issue and
it's for the people of new hampshire
and i hope you folks have the courage to
support this bill thank you and i'll
take any questions
thank you for your testimony you are
excused
at this time we will know
during the public hearing on hb 1027.
the committee will be in recess to
9 25.
hey
uh
um
yeah is
now
is
goes
um
this
is yeah
foreign
bye
um
foreign
oh
um
hey
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill
1027.
does anyone wish to be recognized to
make a motion
representative calmly you were
recognized to make a motion
thank you mr chairman i'd move itl on hb
1027.
representative hearn you wish to second
that motion
do you wish to speak
seeing no hands raised at this time the
matter will now be put to question if
you're in support of the
motion of inexpensive legislate please
say yay if you were opposed
please say nay
the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy
representative welch
representative burrick
representative rhodes
representative greene
clark voties
representative testament
representative leon
representative pratt
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative altschiller
representative o'hearn yes
representative boardnay
representative sullivan
representative newman
yes
representative bolden
representative conley
representative klein knight
representative bradley
chairman avis
the chair votes yes
19 yays zero nays
two not voting
the motion passes
anyone has to move for consent
on consent this time we'll now close the
executive session on house bill
representative marston
representative o'hearn
represented board night
no but the
the microphones are live
okay um i'm wondering if we can exact
any bills that are not on today's docket
we can and we're discussing
we were discussing the
hb 1600
and i think that's what we're going to
move with open right now
i'm wondering because
usually this is on a right to know that
it's not on the calendar for today so
any bills that not on the calendar
i'm not sure are eligible would be exact
actually when the when everything's
noticed it's
in
i'll just read the notice
executive
session on pending legislation may be
held throughout the day time permitting
from the time the committee is initially
convened
so we we are permitted to execute any
bill
that we've already had the public
hearing on
all right thank you
thanks for clarification
representative newman you were
recognized
it's preferred the microphone is on
yeah i just in your explanation i just
wanted to understand it so i understand
process
it would be pending that would include
all previous bills that have not been
have a final vote have not been exact is
that correct
can you can you rephrase that i kind of
yeah i there is a notice on the on the
sheet
and it mentions pending legislation and
i'm just curious as to
that word i believe is the word that
makes it able to be exact because it
includes all legislation that we have
heard and have not
exact on is that correct
yes that and this is exactly how we did
it last year as well
at this at this time we will now open
the executive session on house bill
uh 1600
representative roy you wish to be
recognized to make a motion
i do thank you i would like to move itl
on hp 1600.
did someone wish to second uh
representative marston
representative you wish to speak to your
motion
i do thank you
hp 1600
is relative to
mandatory body cams during custodial
interrogation it conflicts with another
piece of legislation
that um speaks to custodial
interrogation is currently before us
also it
quite possibly is an unfunded mandate
and is therefore unnecessary
seeing no hands raised the matter will
now be put to question if you were in
support of the motion of inexpedient to
legislate please say yay if you were
opposed
please say nay the clerk will now call
the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative burt
representative rhodes
representative greene
clerk votes yes representative testament
representative leon
representative pratt
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative altschiller
representative o'hearn yes
representative bordenay
representative sullivan
representative newman
no
representative bolden no
representative conley
representative klein knight
representative bradley
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
16 yays
three nays one not voting
i don't believe the clerk up the math i
stand corrected yeah 17 yays my mistake
by a vote of 17
days and
three nays
the motion passes
representative hearn
i have a question for the chair is there
going to be the practice today that we
activate our
mics when we're voting also
it is prefer it is preferred that if you
are speaking whether you're voting
or just recognized to speak that you
turn your microphone on and then
immediately thereafter turn it off i i
guess for ryan said only
four microphones can be on at a time
when the red light's on but when your
microphone is off
the there's a speaker that will actually
allow audio for you to hear the
microphone as well also
and i received this criticism a lot that
when the microphone's on the papers
actually for the people watching at home
it
it's very distracting
so if anyone sees them might go on i can
turn them all off it also turns off the
witness one so
can we
if seconded by representative marston
will there be a minority report
any any objection to consent
is there an objection to consent
object objection noted not unconsent
uh at this time we will now
close the executive session on house
bill 1600.
representative newman you got a question
the committee will be in recess until 9
45.
is
you
[Music]
okay being 9 45
committee will now open the public
hearing on hb 1025
and we recognize
representative abbas to introduce the
bill on behalf of representative
balthazar
thank you mr chairman representative
darryl abbott i represent rockingham
district eight
uh the sponsor of the bill i know
couldn't be here today
and
he's actually traveling so
but in speaking with the sponsor
in discussion this bill with it's his
understanding that
a lot of the intent of this bill is
actually already existing law and
therefore i mean there's no process for
him to
withdraw it but he
is withdrawing his support for or the
need for the bill
so i'm introducing it in supporting it
simply to introduce it but i would
encourage any speed to legislate at the
request of the prime sponsor thank you
thank you and i'll be for any questions
during the to the executive session
thank you
yeah but that's his just
oh they're signing in to speak
no nobody signed up
is there anyone else wishing to speak on
hp 1025
there being no one i'm going to close
the public hearing on hp 1025.
is there anyone i'm
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill 1025
relative to
provoking or harassing law enforcement
officers
does anyone wish to be recognized to
make a motion
representative
is there a second
second by representative conley
do you wish to speak to your motion
um
and this time the matter will now be put
to question if you in sport of the
motion of
any speeding to legislate please say yay
if you're opposed
please say name
vice chairman roy
yes
representative welch
representative bert
representative rhodes
yes
representative greene
clark volch yes representative testerman
representative leon yes
representative pratt yes representative
marston
yes
representative harriet
gathright representative altrilla
yes
representative o'hearn yes
representative bordenay
yes
representative sullivan
representative newman yes
representative bolden
yes
representative conley yes
representative klein knight
representative bradley yes chairman
abbas
chair votes yes
19 yays zero nays one not voting
19-0
shouldn't be 21 members of the it's 21
members of the community
so it's two not two numbers
moves for consent
majority report
the assembly will now
close the public hearing the executive
session on house bill 1025
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill 1414.
this time i recognize representative roy
to make a motion
i'd like to move in expedient to
legislate
hp 14-14
is there a second
seconded by representative welch
do you wish to speak to the motion
i do
during public testimony on this bill
we heard from both the state police and
the bill sponsors
the state police
while they admit the capability
is there
they
were reticent to put that onus
on the officers to determine a person's
race
and they also including the sponsor
agreed that it would put the police in
an awkward position to have to inquire
as to race
and we the sponsor included agreed that
the proper solution would be to
make it available on the driver's
license for someone to self-identify
their race should they be so inclined
that would further the purpose of the
bill by getting accurate information
on which
to base future
legislation at best having an officer
guess as to the race
of someone they pull over is going to
lead to
inaccurate information
and possibly complications
and confrontations that are unnecessary
on the roadside
thank you
representative newman
we're now discussing the bill is that
correct
we're in executive session discussing
the bill i want to make sure yes
open questions
in expedition to legislate thank you
although everything that the vice chair
said is absolutely true
i believe it's not the best solution
because we don't have it on the driver's
license now
i think we heard in the testimony
that
a lot of this information
about race and ethnicity is currently
required to be reported
and the officers don't really guess that
uh in the briefing that we that i
attended over at the uh
over on hazen drive
they do have to report it and they they
don't guess
and they don't make a judgment
they ask the person
that has been arrested what their race
in ethnicity is
they're reported in a system that has
drop down menus
and i asked when the testimony was given
that we'd be given a copy of the drop
down menus in order that
people could see and understand what is
available how it's reported and whether
it should be actually part of this
report
and uh
i think that since that information is
already reported people don't guess
people actually do what they said they
did in that briefing
that
in for transparency since that
information is available it could be
included in the report that is required
by this
bill
and so for that reason i will not
support the itl motion thank you mr
chair
representative conley
thank you mr chairman i would add uh
briefly that while i also agree with
much of what the vice chairman had said
there is a solution to that which we
just heard
that we now cannot pursue because the
bill is intended for itl so
uh given that we have identified a
solution would it not be better to
shelve this motion come back with an
amendment to put this information on the
license
and then advance the bill that way
if i may understand are you
the representative are you suggesting
that you would support an amendment put
putting an individual's race on a
driver's license
mr chairman
this question has come before the
committee
many times over the years twice that i
can think of in the last two and we
cannot seem to find a way to get this
data and if that is the only hurdle to
allowing our state agencies to collect
this data then no i would have no
problem with that
well
i'm just trying to i'm going to let
everyone continue to speak and
i don't
i'm all for collecting uh
data on what we need
but i'm trying to understand
why we need this data and what we're
going to do with it
because if we're just going to collect
it
and not use it i see no purpose in
collecting it
does anybody have a reason for
collecting this
representative newman wished to respond
thank you for the opportunity to respond
for some reason
the state police collects that
information i have not had time to
research the law to find out why but the
court system requires that that
information or some
some entity in the government requires
that information i don't know what they
use it for
but since it's available
it would be also something that you they
could reference when they get the
opportunity to make further reports that
we've seen before this committee before
so that they could accurately
put that information in any report
that's
required in the future
and it would be just as accurate as it
is now for the current use thank you
representative roy
thank you mr chairman
i agree with representative
newman that the information is collected
but
there's a distinction it's currently
collected
during arrest
as part of the booking procedure and
that information is required by the fbi
and they use it to compile various
statistics and and things of this nature
that they put out every year with crime
statistics
i think there is value in capturing the
race as well as other
biographical
information on the people
but we have to do it in a proper manner
and what if we do it
roadside versus as it's already done
during arrest
it can lead to problems for example
as part of the citation
the officer says
could you please identify your race well
i'm african-american okay here's your
ticket
it's going to lead to confrontations
that are unnecessary
i also agree with representative conley
that we should in fact have a bill that
enables people not mandates enables
people to self-identify their race on
the driver's license
however
such a bill would not be in this
committee
it would go to transportation it would
require a new bill
um
so
i think the best thing to do is do it
right start from scratch
but i do agree that there is value in
capturing the information so for that
reason i'm going to stay with my
original motion of itl
represent newman you wish to
speak
thank you and um
i i agree with that and and the
officers that gave the briefing that we
saw
went to great lengths that they did not
want to
get the information
on roadside
and i agree with that 100 percent
where i disagree with that is
we get that information
i don't know what the dr what
improvements could be made to the drop
down menu that they use now but maybe in
result of
legislation like this they might redo
their menus but for right now they do it
with arrests and it is accurate enough
for the
fbi
and all i'm pro all i'm saying is that
is wrong by itlling this bill
is that we have a place where they get
information the information is correct
is is collected
and sent to the fbi so we have that
information available that is
suitable for the fbi needs
and i just believe if we have that
information there's no reason why we
could
could not use it if we had if we were
going to require a report here like is
requested in the bill
and
and do it that way i just hate to see
that information going to waste because
we've just done it over and over year
after year and this would be another
year in another year thank you
representative
call me thank you mr chairman quickly
one final point i'll make as we move
toward what appears to be a vote is the
trooper who addressed this committee
indicated that this data would be
extremely useful and go far beyond what
the state police already produces
so again we have a tool that we could
use
by getting by using that tool and
putting it on the license transportation
would have the ability to review this
bill
as a second committee there's ample time
in the session
so
rather than wait another year
i would ask that we maybe take action
now
and we have that uh opportunity thank
you
if i if i miss my inquiry and this is
just a this is an open question
if this report is made by the state
police
what what is the next step with once you
have the report what is the next step
mr chairman the challenge that we have
tried to address and i think
members of both parties in good faith is
getting a better sense
of the demographic data
of people who have interactions with
police
that struggle that we've repeatedly come
up against is the inability to
gather that data
because we keep encountering this
question of
uh
the inability to put police
in the position or the the concern of
putting police in the position of making
guesses
and that's a valid concern
but the point i'm trying to make is we
have a way
of uh of having an official document
that would contain this data how that
data is then used is unanswerable at the
moment but it provides information that
we don't currently have and members of
both parties have indicated they want
so if there's a an interest to gather
data to
investigate
with different different races and what
how often they have interactions with
law enforcement
gathering the data
is one thing what but what does that
actually do to
mitigate or prevent racial profiling i'm
just saying i i you're trying to
identify a problem but to me it's not
that shouldn't be a matter of degree
because once it's one too many in my
mind i think for us
we should still be trying to
prevent that as much as possible and we
would reject that just gathering the
data to me just seems to be
i mean is there a line i don't think
there's a line in the sand that we would
draw and say this is this is acceptable
this is not i think one one time is
unacceptable so what does the data do is
i guess the question
well the data answers
the data tells us who is having
interactions with police and what i
would fully expect
given the law enforcement we've
encountered in this committee and many
many of us know in our community is that
there is not a widespread
problem in our state but i think we
don't know
until we get the data and what would be
tremendous is to see the data
and not see any sort of disparity and to
sort of put this issue to bed but how
would we know until we have the data
it's the circular situation we keep
running up against
i i understand the point but what i'm
saying is even if it it the data
suggests it's not an over happening or
you know overwhelmingly or frequent if
it's still happening that we should be
identifying trying to prevent it from
happening
anytime so i guess i guess my point is
what
is the data going to change anything
that's being done already by law
enforcement and i i would say that i
would think so
but
i raised my man three times you didn't
see me
no i represent remember same cathode i
always try to encourage healthy
conversations i hope my friend from
dover here thinks we're having one but
i'll
i just looked to this side of the room i
apologized it was four hands raised and
i do apologize
but
i would gladly defer to the ranking
member
you but that's the point that i was
trying to make
represent representative harry katherine
you were right i just wanted to add to
it
you asked what's going to happen with
that date it might mean that there's
more training that's available for
policemen you know
that's it's up to them how they fix that
but when i look at racial profiling
which is real and live today
and everyone knows that
so
what do the policemen have to do to
correct that situation because the data
is going to show it and we already have
data from them that shows it and i think
when we first had this bill i don't have
my paperwork with me i literally had a
document a document that was printed and
it gave the data for different towns in
in in terms of racial profiling it was
nashua it was portsmouth it was
manchester and i think it was amherst it
was several
so it happens and i do know that it's
become an issue a training issue as well
and a disciplinary issue
so we you know
i just think that we need more data
we're not getting enough of that data
and furthermore i thought the bill was a
very good bill except that section there
where they said they couldn't they did
say
they could not
tell if someone was late
it was something
and that's what i thought needed to be
carved out of there because they said
they had nothing to do with the number
citations paid late that type of
information remember that was in the
bill
and
when i visited when we went over to
visit okay it was i forget his name i
think it was vetter v-e-t-t-e-r i think
it was
and um when we went over to visit they
actually said that or they have
um
yes race depending on what the situation
is okay and he literally sat there and
said it does happen
they don't want to
but given what that circumstance might
have been when they stopped that person
and maybe they had a feeling that
something was
not quite right
then they've actually checked it off
representative welch
thank you mr chairman i think
overall this is a
bill presents a solution
in search of a problem
i'll support the itl
representative klein knight
thank you mr chair um with all due
prove respect or whether or not people
are being racially profiled
the concern is
that i hear your concern about
having this as a necessary precaution
with would
further the
act of racial profiling but that would
just prove if it is happening
i i understand the point i i think
the message of the question i was
putting out there is i don't believe
anyone is saying that racial profiling
never happens
but saying it never happens i don't
think that that's something anyone's
putting out there what i what i'm saying
is if
having a report telling you how often it
happens
doesn't do anything to prevent it from
happening and i and i understand
where representative harry garfield was
saying that the police if if they see a
report maybe they would adjust their
training to try to identify
ways to prevent it from happening that
often but i would support
that type of additional training whether
it's happening often or not
the idea is we want to prevent it from
happening i don't think the report is
necessary
for us to sit to try to prevent it from
happening that's the point that i'm
making
you you
may respect
it's been
recorded representative o'hearn
i guess i have a just a question maybe
somebody can answer this this
only affects state police
so
i understand that you know
what some of the representatives are
looking to to get information but
it's going to be limited information is
it not just from the state police not
for the towns
and the
other municipalities
it it wouldn't be a full picture with
just pc police
representative bourdain
thank you for sharing i think it's a
point of order uh
uh
are you are you making a point of order
yes i am
you're recognized for your point
representative uh klein knight
as she was speaking was not speaking to
a mic and this is a matter of uh
uh an audience greater than in this room
and i think they would like to hear what
all the reps that are going to be
talking uh
have to say and without a mike
she is silent oh
i
you're right there is first of all there
is
no rule that i'm aware of that says you
have to turn your microphone on
but you should turn your microphone on
uh seeing where the representative is
sitting
there is no microphone at that seat so i
underst i will
we will we will
we will try to accommodate this but we
are in the middle of the executive
session so i
having people move in the middle of the
session is not something that i would
encourage
thank you very much mr chair um i
want to answer a question that you had
posed earlier um what what would we even
do with the data and just to just to
clarify
for you and for the committee that
the department of justice gave out
537 million dollars
in law enforcement professional training
grants
and so
there's a breakdown of all these grants
and a quick
quick search of doj sponsored grants
for law enforcement trainings actually
require this kind of data so we'll we'll
be free to
pursue grant funding which we do with
frequency in our law enforcement
for training purposes
but without this data our applications
become exceptionally weak
and we will get bumped to the bottom of
the line for getting these kind of this
kind of grant training funding um so
that's one reason to collect this data
is that we don't we repl we in the state
of new hampshire
rely heavily
on getting grants that we either meet at
halfway where we pit in half and the
federal government puts in half or some
in a lot of cases the federal government
puts in more than two-thirds um and then
we pony up the other third but without
that
data
we're faced to either make a choice of
not doing certain trainings not having
those trainings available to us or
paying full freight and we can't afford
that so collecting data as anyone who
works in a non-profit or a government
agency knows that's the key to getting
matching funding through the federal
government thank you
if i can inquire has is there any was
there any
information presented to the committee
that suggested that we were the state
whether local or even the state police
were not getting or being denied grants
or funding from the federal government
because
of the lack of report
and i'm asking i actually i couldn't i
wasn't here for the public hearing
myself so that's why i'm asking
if anyone can can address that
no i can't but we've we've discussed a
lot of things that we're not part of
the testimony thank you
um i'd like to i was watching this
public testimony prior um and no that
was not presented from anyone at the
desk
but i will i will tell you from my
perspective and from my experience with
my own local law enforcement and our
county law enforcement if you don't have
all the information it's not worth the
time and effort to apply for those
grants and you end up leaving money
potential money on the table for your
county leaving money on the table for
your municipality and we could be
leaving money on the table for our state
police so um
saying that you know well have we ever
been denied are we even applying because
you know why put an application in that
you can't finish
so let's give our state police more data
let's give our state more data and let's
see what we can do with that and make
something useful of it
if i may inquire would would the
representative support an amendment
that would put an individual's race on
the driver's license
at this time i would support tabling
this motion so that
an appropriate amendment can be crafted
that i believe the prime sponsor had
reached out to members of this committee
to do
but if if if an amen at the amendment
included that putting race on on the
driver's license because i know that
that's been discussed in the past and
it's been a
animated discussion so i'm just i
understand why you might go that
direction i'm just wondering if that's
something that would be supported
is that for me yes
so if that is supported by the prime
sponsor and i believe the prime sponsor
had conversations with other people on
this committee i would support with
withdrawing the motion to itl so that an
amendment and a better offer a better
motion can be made thank you
representative newman
and the only reason i want to speak
again is because there were three of us
that actually had a briefing on this
from the state police
and i think that the information that
that
exists
that is only taken when someone is
arrested
showed how poor the input mechanism is
in the software to be able to check
those it's other or not
i don't remember exactly what they are
but they were insufficient
and i think having that data that is
already collected
in a proper manner and is available if
that could be included in a report
that report would then be something that
could be used in a lot of different
places as has been already testified to
to help
not only
get it on the license plate because
people would understand what the issues
are with that
it would
it would just also help to inform other
localities that might be able to use
whatever funds are available
to improve their training based upon
whatever that information showed as a
conclusion as to what is going on when
police inter when people interact with
the police thank you
representative bourdain
thank you mr chair um
well we can
we can acknowledge that race is uh
a controversial
item for this particular bill
other uh items in the
data that was being gathered is also not
available for
law enforcement
at that time for example the number of
citations
issued the number of citations paid late
and etc
those are not available to uh
the agency
and i for that reason and that reason
alone i would suggest that we contin do
we uh itl just build
thank you
representative klein knight
thank you chair um i can't speak for
all of my colleagues but i would support
an amendment that includes
race identification markers but also
prefer not to disclose
i think based on the
conversations we've had and everyone's
had a chance to speak i think what we
can do is
move the question and then we will go
from there and
so this time
the matter will now be
them
at this time the matter will now be put
to question if you were in support of
the motion of inexpensive legislate
please say
yay if you were opposed please say nay
the clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy
yes
clerk votes yes representative testerman
representative leon yes
representative pratt yes
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative altschiller no
representative o'hearn
yes
representative bordnay yes
representative sullivan
no
representative newman
representative bolden
no
representative
conley no
representative klein knight no
representative bradley no
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
12 eas
eight nays and one not voting
there'll be a minority report
there's a lot of authority so
uh welch which brave soul wants to
challenge
representative colony with the majority
report
representative roy
make sure it's good
at this time we will now close the
executive session on
house bill 1414.
the community will be will be in recess
until 10 30.
watch me
at this time we now open the
we now open the public hearing on
house bill
and
we'll recognize representative manny
espitia representative good to see you
thank you mr chair thank you mr vice
chair thank you committee my name is
representative manny espitia i bring you
before y'all hb1 1117 um basically a
bill to
uh that would
that would
uh increase the
my apologies to the world
sorry about that
um
basically this bill came out of what
happened to me in 20 um
what is it now like 2020
was it last year even how do you
remember um
in may of
of last year with um you know in in my
city of nashua on my in my community
um we had defacement of public property
we had on the national rail trail it's
which is a you know a very
um actually it was last year sorry um
you know this is a pathway that most
people most of my constituents walk
through it's in the middle of my
district um and there was defacement by
these by this this this neo-nazi group
um that basically put in you know this
put swastikas
they put up um
this uh this you know
make new england white
um and it's a just incredibly um you
know threatening to to a population of
people that most of my cons have a
pretty large latino district i think the
largest in the state
um and so
and you know and also anti-semitic like
i said so hurting the folks who are also
of that faith uh who live in that area
so
you know this would be
this bill would aim to target like you
know things like this where the public
you know public place a place that many
constituents walk through many cases get
to see
would have you know would
it would basically make it so that you
know if somebody were to do things like
this that we would that that law
enforcement could get involved and
could actually do something do something
to actually try to get folks like this
it would also add you know issues around
discrimination
um for our
um for our you know that target certain
groups
these groups have been you know i put
these this list of folks together from
uh
from some of the you know from the
language that was recently added into
our budget from last year um so you know
i think
nobody deserves to live in fear nobody
should be worried about you know whether
they're taking their dog out for a walk
whether they're you know going out to
downtown to grab a drink with a friend
on their way out there to feel like
their life is being threatened feel like
they've uh like that they that their
faith is being is being threatened so
um you know i put this bill out there
and then the other reason was because
after you know i called this called this
public defacement out the group went
after myself
and so i
you know just as they are going after
folks right now in the seacoast it's
it's it's it's wrong and we want to be
able to try to get you know get folks
like this and uh and you know be able to
to be uh be able to to to prosecute them
so um with that you know i can answer
any questions
um but i hope that y'all take it uh take
a look at this legislation and hope i
hope that you all have a chance to pass
it so
representative baldur
thank you for taking my question
representative espedia um
when
those images appeared on the nashua rail
trail
um was there a particular group that
claimed ownership of them yeah it was um
thank you for the question as nfc 131
was the group that
claimed credit for that
and it wasn't that wasn't the first
defacement they've had of
public property in
nashua
they had had other other areas around
downtown around the southern part of the
city so um and as you can see now other
parts of the state so
phillip
you're recognized for a follow-up thank
you very much um representative spedia
are you aware of any other um
instances around the state where
groups like this
or other hate-based groups have
threatened
uh citizens with posters or flyers
in their communities yeah i uh thank you
for the question yeah definitely i've
seen it in uh like i said in the
seacoast right now
uh recently with um the targeting of a
certain um uh it was a theatrical group
so um yeah i mean it's real it's it's
out there still and uh it's really
unfortunate is that
if i may inquire of a question was the
individuals who uh
made made their spray painted the
graffiti
what not what what was the consequence
of that
um i mean currently there hasn't been
any consequences for them they haven't
been um
nobody has been brought in for charges
against them i know that it's probably
an active investigation but nothing has
been done of yet
and
my my follow-up question is and i'm just
if spray painting
uh graffiti on public property isn't
that
a crime already so i'm just wondering is
there any i don't i don't know the
answer is what's happening with the
status that yeah i think you know and i
have i have friends who participate in
graffiti art um some get commissioned
and they get to put it up and they get
paid for it but this so i'm i'm not
against the practice of graffiti on like
especially with commission but you know
specific targeting of groups of hate of
hate speech that's when i think you know
when art i think believe crosses that
line so
representative newman you were
recognized
thank you mr chair
as i read the bill this is this is not
aimed at just plain graffiti
and it appears that it says the property
of another with the purpose to coerce or
terrorize any person or the people of
and then it has several characteristics
is that a correct understanding of what
you intend with the bill right so yeah
the first section b addresses graffiti
section uh c addresses uh property much
l is a much broader
um
aim at just property also owned by
another um and i'll be i'll be clear
very open to any amendments that the
committee would like to do on the spell
as well
follow up
mr representative newman you're
recognized
uh and it also appears that that phrase
about terrorizing and coercing is in all
three
paragraphs is that correct right thank
you
representative rory
thank you mr chairman uh thank you for
taking my question
um
so the the current law
already has the part about the the
coercion and terrorizing any person
this this adds public property
but then it goes on
so my question is why is it necessary to
add all the different
different identities when the current
loss is any person
uh thank you for the question i think um
i think because of like for example this
instance which is not this isn't an
isolated instance as we've seen already
this year
um has been targeted specifically
because of a person's you know uh sexual
orientation uh
people's faith and people's uh
race and ethnicity specifically it
wasn't like
like ex-person you are the worst or it
wasn't like it was it was specifically
directed um at a at a certain at these
different groups so
thank you
representative klein knight um thank you
chair
thank you representative espedia
what happens to communities when
this kind of hate crime goes uh
unpunished
you know i thank you for the question i
i think
folks start to
well there's two things one people start
feel
um
feel a little bit more struck to their
core about how they feel as a person i
know especially if if my i'll put it as
an example if i was if i some
anti-catholic you know rhetoric thrown
at me
i would feel a little bit more shocked
to my you know my belief as a catholic
united understand do i feel safe
which is you know for a lot of for a lot
of people the jewish faith that is
somehow how they feel probably at this
moment
um so that's one and two
one of the one of the few silver linings
of the situation that happened
was that a i think the community just
became a little bit closer and had knows
that you know they had to stick together
so it served as a point of like you know
we need to come together at this point
but then b also
i think folks started looking into it
and taking it a little bit more
seriously
represent klein knight you recognize for
a follow-up
thank you chair thank you uh
representative espidia um
would you say
because it goes unaddressed as you were
just saying uh that it would embolden
more hate crimes possibly leading to
what we experienced and witnessed in
texas last week um thank you for the
question
i mean i think
when you know
things escalate so when one thing
happens it goes unchecked they think it
just continues to grow and it's you know
i wouldn't want to link the two things
together but i would say that there i
personally think there is been a rise in
anti-semitism in our in our country and
i think you know
part of it is we gotta we gotta step it
up and you know address it so
representative bolden
thanks for taking my question
um
so pardon me i'm just trying to
understand your intent with bill
um
it seems like your intent and i my
question is am i representing it
correctly i'm you know active listening
i just want to say back to you and make
sure i understand
is do i understand correctly that your
intent is that if an action
is considered criminal threatening
against an individual but we should
expand that to also be considered
criminal threatening
that we should expand criminal
threatening to include actions that are
directed not at an individual but at a
group an unspecified generic group
basically so if someone says
you know i'm going to kill joe
that's that's criminal threatening
currently and you want to expand that
criminal threatening to be i'm gonna
kill
all people who share joe's
characteristics whether or not i can
name them right
so that's okay thank you
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um
i'm actually reading um pretty much what
representative roy read
it i mean it actually says criminal
threatening by physical conduct the
person purposely places or attempts to
place another in fear of imminent bodily
injury or physical contact
i think i'm just failing to realize what
it what is the difference it
i mean it actually says that place
another in fear or imminent bodily
injury
um
that's a good question i appreciate the
question um
so i think
so like i'm trying to park in this back
to the exam like what the situation that
happened to myself like i think
um
i think it wasn't originally like you
know it wasn't a
it mentioned it and i said you know we
want like when people directed i mean we
want people like you out
like like does that you know what does
that mean um
like and i think for myself i see that
as
like do we want to like like remove
people that look like yourself so i
think
i think looking at this as more of
looking at a larger idea of like okay so
it's not just myself but also like these
groups is what i'm trying to get the aim
out of like trying to expand it so make
sure that you know people who are
targeted because of their
their their their race their religion
their disability things like that that
they that they are more protected as
well under this
rep representative harry gathered
i was trying to figure out how i want to
say this
when i look at the addition with the
people one age sex gender those types of
terms
i look at that as being person
so when it says any person
i think would cover all of that
this is just a thought
but i would add the religion and
national origins
but i do believe that the term person
would cover all the others that are
listed there
okay
was there a question there well
it's not a question that's a comment i
think do i make a question
would you be open to amending yes i
would be i
yeah as i mentioned i would be open to
amending this and even if we wanted to
have a have a work session on it
representative harry gareth the former
chair of this committee has taught me
well
representative newman
i believe that if they're referring to
rsa 631
colon 4.
and if you are looking that up if you do
go to the end of that rsa there is a
definition for the term terrorize
thank you
and this time i want to thank the
representative for his testimony
thank you thank y'all
we will
right at this time we have to just
recognize you
at this time the committee will
recognize
teresa grinnell
there we go
thank you for the opportunity to have
public hearings and to discuss these
matters absolutely under the
circumstances of having um
something anti-semitic on a railway is
very alarming and not appropriate and
not okay i would hope that we already
have littering bills and hate crime
bills laws that could be applied to
groups especially when we can identify
who did those types of acts
the only thing the reason i wanted to
speak is that it talks about anything
that would coerce um in that includes
like religion and national origin
so my question is would this
potentially be used that if say someone
said
you know the catholic church is having a
potluck sunday at 2 p.m open to the
public and they put it at an
intersection
is that public coercion
to participate in a specific race it
just it feels like as we keep putting
more and more legislation on the books
that sometimes then later on you know
someone put
an elected official
at an intersection that's a public
spot is that now coercion
for that political party that political
elected official like i just don't want
to stifle free speech
when it's maybe coercion but not
a hate crime so i guess the definition
of coercing people to
um participate in a special group
would be at all
at some point stifled
in and unintentionally by what's trying
to be accomplished here but that would
just be a concern that i would have in
the way it's currently written so it
might need to be amended to make sure
that we don't paint ourselves into a
corner would be my concern
thank you
representative klein knight
thank you chair
um most of this is already law um
would a potluck inspire fear or terror
in you if you saw it at an intersection
it does state coerce or terrorize so if
it coerces someone but gosh i didn't
know that we had i know i'm just
throwing it out there satanists in our
community that are doing a potluck
tomorrow afternoon you know what i mean
would that
you know coerce people to go check that
out and with that then it'd be in
violation of this i mean i'm just
i know that the intent is one thing but
i think we have to be very careful when
we put things on the books
that two three four five years down the
road it's all all of a sudden considered
that because someone's
of a certain faith that maybe
doesn't believe in same-sex marriage and
that's their right to that religion to
that belief
is now terrorizing someone who is in a
same-sex marriage and feels that that is
not something they want to see at the
intersection and it just happens to be a
catholic church having a potluck so i
just think that we've seen things go
you know
we have laws on the book for littering
we have laws on the book for true hate
crimes
i think that when we say coerce that's a
very loose word
and for people to be stifled their
freedom of speech
whether it be their national origin
whether it be their religion
it might offend somebody else that i'm a
christian it might offend somebody that
i'm a republican at some point you know
and so
right so
we just want to make sure that we're not
putting things on the books that later
on could be used to someone hang their
hat on i mean heaven forbid you get
arrested for saying the word amen as you
said quietly you know things are
happening that are very alarming to us
in the public
poll
can i be recognized for paul
you you're not recognized for a fall
thank you thank you for your testimony
at this time we will now close the
public hearing on
hp 1117.
you
so
at this time we're gonna
we'll open the executive session on
house bill
1117.
i'm not recognizing any member to make
any motion
i just open up for discussion
and
it's just
in in what when you're saying that what
would if there were to be an amendment
you would one be recognized you would
have to be recognized for an ought to
pass but would that amendment
uh
so what i just
my interpretation of what this would do
c and d
i i don't think i think under existing
law
would already cover what the objective
is
specifically
you know making a threat to commit a
crime against the property of another
you you that's you that's someone else's
property you're threatening to commit a
crime against that
to corrosive terrorize the person
terrorizes defined as
means to cause alarm fright or dread
state of mind induced by the
apprehension of hurt
from someone hostile or threatening
or threatening event or manifestation
so i'm just
my interpretation is that c and d would
already cover the intent i guess the
question really
is
b you're adding public property as
opposed to a property of another
and then
the only other question i would pose is
would that
if that graffiti or was that was a hate
message whether it's based on religion
race whatever would would that already
be covered under the definition of
terrorize now i understand what happened
in nashua it didn't lead to any
prosecution or arrest so that's the
concern that
that's just open for discussion it's not
representative rhodes
thank you mr chairman
so when the representative spoke
if if i'm not mistaken
i do believe that he's that there was a
question asked and his answer was
that
the people were fearful
and that about making them uncomfortable
and you know was this
were they being specifically targeted so
he specifically did use the word fear
and
i mean it clearly definitely says that
right here under a it
attempts to place another in fear
another i do believe is meant to be
anybody anybody
regardless of
of who you are or what you look like you
are a person
i i just don't see what what this bill
is going to do anything different
i'm also a little i'm a little confused
why if the person was not authorized by
law to
spray paint or make graffiti on the wall
but there was nothing done about that
that's not a question really we can
answer i just i don't
it seems to me that that regardless of
the intent this this mere act of the
graffiti is is a crime
it's my understanding we have a bill on
that coming up so maybe
just putting that out there
representative sullivan um
no tag
it it seems to me that the
the way that it's written now
it's specific to terrorizing a person
not a class of people but a person
so if you put up a piece of graffiti
that says
kill brian sullivan
you're terrorizing me
if it's if you put up a piece of
graffiti that says kill the gays
you're
you're terrorizing
not a person
but a class of people
and i think this bill
would therefore be helpful to
guide
law enforcement to say
this is terrorizing a group of people a
class of people and it therefore would
perhaps result in uh prosecution which
as yet hasn't happened in the case that
representative speedy have cited
thank you
representative klein knight
thank you chair um yes uh with
uh representative rhodes is correct i
believe that this is more of a
housekeeping bill we need to amend it
and we
simply if we add any person or peoples
if we click if we correct some grammar
we would be cleaning up the entire thing
we might not need all this but
um if we add a class of people rather
than a singular person
i think we would be protecting and doing
everyone justice by this
representative marston
thank you thank you mr chairman i have a
question of his history of this
situation in this case
were the police involved do we know and
did any action
been taken by law enforcement
and someone correct me if i'm wrong my
understanding that and this was
this incident that inspired this bill
was covered in the media
i so i would presume that the law
enforcement is aware of the situation
and what i understand is that there was
no arrest despite the fact that an
organization took credit for
what they did
so
i'm i'm not sure why it was not ending
done beyond that point
representative
thank you mr chairman for letting me
speak um my question is about the
threats sorry my comments about the
threats to groups if it says death to
gays would every single person who sees
that who fits that description
individually already be terrorized by
that and have it covered by the statute
that's already there and also i question
if if this case that was clearly an
egregious statement and should have been
prosecuted wasn't do we fix it by
creating more laws or we try and figure
out why this wasn't taken seriously in
the first place
wallace thank you mr chairman just um
one of the
stark facts about crime and punishment
is the
capacity by which
these can be dealt with um
presently we're
seeing some of the unintended
consequences of bail reduction bail
reform and
reducing a lot of the crimes that we
actually prosecute consequently
we have a lot of property crimes that
are going unprosecuted by deliberate
action or lack thereof by county
attorneys across all ten counties here
in new hampshire they are understaffed
and unable to prosecute these types of
crimes so unless and until
there's actual harm done and although i
certainly appreciate the terror that may
be
instilled or
may be caused i don't believe i don't
want this to sound harsh that there's
any actual harm done here and as such
how can it be prosecuted
now this on the committee this this
occurred in nashua there's two
representatives from nashua did do you
have any additional information
represent numero representative harry
catholic you can provide
on
what was done at the local level by law
enforcement
a group claimed attribution
but i don't think that that is probably
enough evidence to do anything with it
so i i assume that there was some reason
why they did not
prosecute it
i'm still baffled i mean this
illegal graffiti spray painted on the
wall
hate crime aside
that's that's against the law
a group owned up to doing it and nothing
was done about it i mean i'm just i'm
just i'm not even this bill aside i find
that hard i'm just wondering that's what
happened i'm just wondering
i'm not a lawyer but i'm just wondering
if
uh the nashua police department could
could um
prosecute the hate group
that um took attribution for it or who
was it that that how did they do it did
they just write a statement that we did
it or whatever i'm just i would think
that that would be a difficult
prosecution if they even could do that
it's
my my humble opinions it's easy to
prosecute a crime when they admit to
admit to it but i see the point that
you're making that the org you can't
prosecute an organization but if you
know who they is you could
representative bouldin
since we're executing this now and not
um after we can research i've been
researching during the
discussion now and
um
it looks like in nashua
there was a man in nashua who spray
painted some
swastikas in concord
and he was charged with
criminal mischief
and
not criminal threatening and the
swastikas were spray-painted like on or
near
the home of a
person
who's a new american so like a refugee
um so that's definitely
about their
origin
and
their entry into the country
and he was charged with criminal
mischief
there was a teenager
in manchester who was spray painting
swastikas on things he was charged with
criminal mischief
and
then there were a couple of
men who were spray painting their
initials
all over the city in manchester and the
highways
and they were charged with criminal
mischief so it seems that and this is in
the last five for six years
um
so it does seem like
the application of the law currently is
that regardless of whether what you're
spray painting or graffiti
is intended to
terrorize someone or whether you're just
claiming a portion of the retaining wall
on the side of the highway for yourself
and putting your initials on it it's
treated the same
and that doesn't seem appropriate given
the intent behind the use of swastikas
for example
so i just wanted to share that
so at
just a thought at 11 15 there's a bill
schedule that is actually
would address criminal mischief so maybe
it would make sense for us to
well
just
finish the sentence
perhaps we can
we can um
recess the executive session and maybe
hear testimony on the criminal mission
film maybe come back to this
representative klein knight thank you
chair i have some more information
um
i just want to say uh
representative
wallace asked
you know um
where does the buck stop why isn't
anybody prosecuting this
exactly
and i have to say as leaders we set an
example and i have to say i'm really
concerned with the example we've been
setting currently at the in the state
legislature on anti-semitism and i want
to share some actual facts with you
within the last term this term on 12 17
20 in hanover a menorah was shot and
desecrated on 12 320 in nashua swastikas
and neo-nazi logo on stickers in 1220
laconia synagogue received harassing
anti-semitic emails from a white
supremacist on 10 20 concord is still
under investigation on what happened in
conquer but there's a thing there in in
raymond in in 820 a swat sticker was
painted on us on a sign at a high school
on in 6 20 a temple billboard defaced
with swastika and other racist words in
320 in tilton a mailbox was vandalized
with swastikas and sss bots and 220 in
merrimack a student made a nazi salute
in class in 220 in laconia a flyer with
an image of a gun shooting star of davis
with threatening caption placed on
sanders campaign in 221 in plainfield
desecration of a monument in saint
goddess national historical site with
swastikas and anti-semitic images and
now we are
not doing a simple housekeeping bill so
we're showing our public that it is okay
to just treat these as representative
bolden said in
just plain crimes when it is in fact a
crime of terror and hate
thank you representative knight
so what i'll do
we will now recess the executive session
on
house bill 1117.
and the committee will be in recess to
11 15.
at this time
back up
thank you representative
at at this time we are going to open the
public hearing on house bill
10 11.
and this time we'll recognize
representative david welch
thank you sir
thank you mr chairman for the record i'm
david a welch i represent rockingham
district 13.
and this bill is one that we heard
last year
as part of a senate omnibus bill
so this is a
another try
this would make uh
criminal mischief a class a misdemeanor
which means there could be
charges of class a misdemeanor depending
on the type of
crime crime
was or could be
down
to where it is presently as a violation
this was brought to my attention uh last
year
the chief of staff he's here to testify
on this bill
and uh we have
had to pay some considerable sums
on public property and it has been
defaced and tampered with
and i think that this is a a good bill
and
lo and behold yesterday
obama chief charlie reynolds who was a
member of this committee in 1996 he
called me out of the blue and he
supports this bill so
take that for what it's worth
that i'll take any questions
thank you representative you are excused
the committee now calls terry faff
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee for the record my name is
terry poff i'm the chief operating
officer for the general court of new
hampshire
um this legislation was initially
brought forward with partnership between
the department of justice
the gcnh ourselves the general court das
we were having some troubles on the
front state house plaza
and we really weren't at all able to
charge anybody with anything prior to
the last year's legislation getting
passed as representative welch indicated
with that omnibus bill so that made at
least a violation so we could go up the
original draft of this was from the
department of justice the ag's office
who wanted it as a misdemeanor because
you can always go down from a
misdemeanor as you know but you can't go
up from a violation so in some of the
severity of of some of the defacements
and even things that are happening today
we're in a kind of a different political
profile so folks that advocate or
protest for different things out there
seem
to get a little more um on edge and a
little more violent especially with some
of the public properties
so the the defacement has gotten to be a
point where it can
really should raise to a misdemeanor
level in my opinion and an opinion of
the department of justice at least have
that chargeability so that they can
bring it down if they have to in a
bargain plea bargain or something
so that's a little of the history of
where it came from and we still
have certain
issues out there i won't say they're
problems they're challenges because the
state house plaza is the is this town
square for for the state so it's there
it's a place where people exercise the
first amendment rights we want them to
we encourage them to do that out there
as a body and as an institution
but we wanted to do it peacefully and
without damaging
the property that's out there that
everybody can enjoy
for instance we have things that happen
out there that you wouldn't want your
fourth graders walking by the next
morning when they're coming in to take a
tour
so these things
it could prove to be a deterrent that's
what the goal is of this is that if it's
a violation it's a ticket if it's a
misdemeanor it's something a little more
substantial and it may
create a deterrent as is what we really
want nothing to happen but their active
ability to exercise their first
amendment rights
so with that i'll
take any questions mr chairman members
of the committee
with that thank you very much appreciate
it you are excused
representative welch i may ask inquire
of a question
can i may inquire of a question
so it's it's a class a misdemeanor the
prior witness
mentioned
pleading it down
which
i i understand
you know how that could work but it
any thought on if it just said
misdemeanor so it can be charged as an a
or b
and obviously if it's an a it can be
played down to a b
is that
an amendment that you perhaps
have any opinion on
my understanding is it
as a class a misdemeanor it can be
charged as a class b or
uh
or violation
all depends on the crime
i always understood it and someone
correct me if i'm wrong i
act like i'm always right but i'm not
if it says just misdemeanor that gives
the discretion to pick an a or a b if
it's expressly states a or expressly
states b
then that's what it's charged as so
was going to say if it just said
misdemeanor there will be the discretion
to
start with an a
ple down to a b but if it's already
you can't go up but you can go down
i'm not sure you can plead this down to
a violation because it says shall be
guilty of
class a misdemeanor you would have to
amend the charge
to something different which does does
happen but that's
this has a restitution figure in there
as well so you may lose that by amending
the charge
i agree with that as you generally
described it
so
i think
my impression is that if you say
misdemeanor you could do a or b
i don't know if you could go from
misdemeanor down to to a violation
but i think that would at least give you
the discretion if you said misdemeanor
that it could be charged as a
misdemeanor where in this case it has to
be charged as a class a
that's just how i think about that
does the prime sponsor have any
opinion on that
i also support it as written i i don't
have a problem with
how it's written i just throw it out
yeah i guess
mr chairman i would
rely on the fact that the a.g
crafted the uh
the language i would go with that
to testify again
you may ask a question
uh thank you uh mr chairman and thank
you for your testimony
um
i guess what i would like to see more
too
you know which i don't know how you can
do this you know but be more specific on
what
private property is
but i also would support the bill more
if it just said misdemeanor
basically
for public property this is what
instituted the change
um
i don't want to reference january 6 in
washington but it could have happened
here and all the destruction and so
forth it seems kind of foolish that if
we only had a violation
to cover that destruction of property
that would be kind of foolish
representative parent catholic you
recognize for a question
um
i don't i don't uh believe that i think
the the class a misdemeanor would cover
uh
the more violent uh
things that can happen
uh it can certainly be uh
brought down to a class b
and it can be brought down to a
violation all depends on on the plea
bargain it won't have a plea bargain but
it's a violation
and the warby won't be any restitution
that's
that's what happened uh we had some uh
some destruction out in the front of the
state house and it was very costly to
repair
in fact the sundial out there i think we
spent a few thousand dollars to replace
that
it's all public money all taxpayer money
representative harry gathered
i'm sorry i didn't hear you
i apologize
i remember that i they thought those
were it was young people that did that
destruction
and i
yeah well i kind of struggle with you
know a class a i mean that you could be
doing jail time
oh depending on the age chances are
there wouldn't be any jail time with
those kids
that's
that's an issue if that's not
i really don't know how to get into that
okay but if it's a if it's a class a
misdemeanor
uh it it will act as a deterrent i'm
sure it'll be posted
okay
thank you representative you are you are
excused again thank you
at this time we will close the public
hearing on house bill
1011.
um
things don't normally operate this
smoothly
question for the chair
all i'm all i'm saying is uh
so i'm just gonna get a feel for the
committee now we we can recess until
12 o'clock we have a 12 o'clock hearing
i'm not sure if that's long enough
enough time for everyone to enjoy lunch
for lunch
we're not officially in recess i'm
inquiring if
a representative needs time to get an
amendment
i did
before before opening
before opening an executive session i'm
asking if the representative would need
time to
get an amendment if he does not we can
open it now
that's the nature and spirit of our
conversation
it can be
yes
correct
because
at this time we are now going to open
the executive session on house bill
10 11 10 11
representative welsh you wish to be
recognized to make a motion
i move house bill 1011 fn
we found
ought to pass
that has been seconded by rep
representative martin just a second
it's with great pleasure i second the
motion
thank you representative marston
uh representative welch do you wish to
speak to the motion about to pass
no i think we've
just had the hearing i think everything
is fresh in everybody's mind
except maybe for those who have been
sleeping
representative boardney
thank you mr chairman um i was
originally opposed to this bill because
it
required a class to be a class a
misdemeanor
and um
by reading the rsas i see that
any offense
charged as a class a misdemeanor to like
class b misdemeanor anytime with the
agreement of the person charged
so
though it may be a reason maybe charge
class
egg misdemeanor uh the parties involved
can plead it down to a
class b and class b misdemeanor
does not have any prison time
so based on
the severity of the crime
the punishment can be suitable
representative conley
thank you mr chairman what i like about
this bill and i intend to support it is
that it offers some teeth particularly
for cases of
vandalism
and as we heard from two bills ago
there seemed to be some problems
addressing it i believe up to a year in
jail
is a pretty uh substantial
penalty and it offers an enhancement
under the current law to address the
situation we heard two bills ago so i
will support this
representative burke
thank you mr chairman
um again i wished it was just a
misdemeanor
but
where i guess my concern is
and i really believe the majority of our
police would not do this
um but you get some kid
you know 18 19
and he chocks
the front of the state house or
something like that it's not permanent
but he could still be charged
and what concerns me is you know there
goes this college and everything else
because the charge is there
so i guess i just have to look at that
um
that i wished it was more
defined to
you know a set amount of money or
or a set damage because i do support the
bill to a point um but again i just wish
it was a misdemeanor
which would make me a little easier
but
you know some kid chalk and
you know a sidewalker or a
side of a building
really shouldn't be facing jail time
over that
thank you
it
at this time that matter will now be put
to question if you support the motion of
ought to pass
please say yay if you were opposed
please say nay the clerk will now call
the roll
vice chairman roy
representative welch yes
representative burt
no
representative rhodes
yes
representative greene yes
clerk votes yes representative testerman
yes
representative leon yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
yes representative harriet gathright
representative altschiller
no
representative o'hearn
yes
representative bordenay yes
representative sullivan yes
representative newman
no
representative bolden
representative conley yes
representative klein knight yes
representative bradley yes
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
there were 16 years five nays
would it be a minority report
no this isn't a hill i want to die on
anyone wish to
represent wells you you'll be preparing
a majority report
this at this time we'll now close the
executive session
on house bill 1011
question of the chair
representative newman yeah
my understanding every committee has
their reports and before the end of the
day
i am a little more lenient it has to be
by noontime
the following day because sometimes
we're here late
but if it's not received by then i spent
more time tracking down reports
i i understand that and i understand
that and if it's not in by that time and
you haven't
discussed it with me in advance it's
going to be rejected and you'll have to
take it up with the speaker's office
thank you a lot of time goes it goes
into that
at this time we will now open the
executive session on house bill 1117.
representative conley
you should be recognized
mr speaker um i believe we had a healthy
discussion
uh percolating earlier this morning and
i think it would be healthy to continue
that discussion uh just for a little
while longer to consider possible
amendments
but representative roy you wish you
should be recognized
i would move
in expedient to legislate on house bill
uh 11 17.
is there a second
no no
the motion cannot be seconded or made by
assad
seconded by representative testament
i believe that you told us as a group
that if we had amendments that you would
not exactly
is there but what let me ask you let me
ask this question what would that
amendment
look like
i don't it was on people's and i think
it was on uh
religion
and national origins
i spoke to it he was amendable to
amendment so i'm i'm just not sure
so my my review of the bill
c and d i don't think has changed under
the existing law
you don't need to specify anything
beyond person it's really the paragraph
b it's expanding to public property then
whether the
target of the vandalism is
is it
a class of individuals as opposed to a
specific person
what
my my understanding is by changing that
what would the change to that paragraph
be that you would like to make on b and
d on just the sub paragraph b if there
was an amendment that you were to
bring forward
religion
was the um
key factor there
so you would you would
prefer to strike religion no i want
religion in there
religion we were striking
some of the classes because i felt that
persons would also identify as classes
it doesn't you know
in my opinion
either way the point of the matter is
like i said that
what you have told us is that if we
thought we had amendments
um that you would not exact so i guess
what you're saying if you agree
we would not exec but if you disagree
i'm wondering you know how did we get to
where we are right now in this meeting
in this committee
my i think when we recessed the last
this this executive session
hospital 11 17 the
purpose was that there was a
bill on criminal mischief that would
involve
vandalism in spraying graffiti on public
property which
is what this bill also is addressing
so we addressed that in the last hearing
so my my understanding is if
the prior bill which was
was it house built 10 11.
i'm just explaining i mean you asked the
question to answer it so what i'm saying
is
in this scenario regardless of what the
graffiti is it's now a class a it would
be a class a misdemeanor
that where under the current law
it's a violation so a person spray
painting
you know racist hate symbols on public
property is is a violation it's a ticket
it's now going to be a class a
misdemeanor so i think the idea is that
the mere fact that they're spray
painting on the on that property or
doing that is now a class a misdemeanor
the
intent of what the symbol is
i don't i think
i'm not saying that's irrelevant that
matters but it
for the purposes of the elements of the
offense
it wouldn't have to prove that it was
targeted at a group of people it's the
mere fact of doing the act
i'm reading between the lines here but
that seems to me seems to me to think
why was nothing done about what happened
maybe that's because it was a violation
and it's a ticket
so even if you found the person who in
the person owned up to it
you were writing them a ticket
apparel that's that's what you would be
doing
i understand that it's a misdemeanor now
i'm clear about that but this is more
house cleaning as well
because it's more specific
and
just to go back to my original comment
was what you told us as a group
and what you're doing now is different
i i i understand that i already i've
recognized someone for emotion of
inexplaining to legislate i
representative newman
thank you i i'm
i just want to clarify what we are now
in executive sessions yes and the
question is
motion has been made
to inexpensive legislation
okay i understand that and now we have
the ability to
make comments or questions or
what what may we do at this point
in this executive session
okay we are debating the question of the
motion of inexpensive legislate
that is what the question has been
is going to be moved i am
you are free to speak in support
or against
follow-up
you're recognized to speak in support or
against
or say you're undecided you have been
recognized i don't know what else i can
do that thank you beyond that
um
well the previous bill does uh
uh state a uh
misdemeanor for uh
mischievous uh conduct and
but that is that the
most likely the penalty
that would incur
would
be based on the amount of cost for the
damage
and this bill
even though it does talk about
uh on private property
the intent
or the damage could be
very small as far as cost-wise
but
the
intent of the crime is to
be terroristic are
for someone
to
fear for
their safety
so i can't see that those two
these two matters are equivalent even
though the penalty is the same because
with intent we have uh
different really two different crimes
being committed
thank you
representative roy you're recognized
thank you mr chairman
um the reason i'm moving in expedient to
legislate
is because
in in my mind any person covers all all
these additions
and when you try to add
classes or or
any type of specialized group of people
to a bill like this
you're inevitably going to leave some
out um i don't see veterans
um and and i'm you know
we could be offended just as well
there's other groups there's there's
lots of groups so the best way is to be
all-inclusive by saying persons
and it covers everybody when we try to
give special status we invariably leave
somebody out that's why it's best to be
all-inclusive and that's why i'm moving
the way i am
representative klein knight
thank you chair uh representative
uh roy is correct it doesn't say persons
it just says person which is why it
needs to be amended and updated and
also
with all due respect the exasperation
from my colleagues
is really disappointing as a jewish
member of this house
and
i want
to ask the chair that if he thinks
criminal mischief is the same thing as a
hate crime
is that a question
it's a completely different crime
then why are we having this conversation
with you trying to loop it into the
other bill of criminal mischief
you're asking for the intent of the last
comment i made
i and i the point that i was making
was when there was graffiti spray
painted on the wall and an organization
took credit for doing that
and
it was a hate symbol i was concerned why
there was no
prosecution or charges brought against
any individual and i thought that to be
very odd
it was on public property in the mere
fact of the spray painting
hate symbol aside i was my understanding
against law
the next bill thereafter involved
graffiti on public property
and in that case it's changing from a
violation to a class a misdemeanor so
the point that i was making
is that
the hate symbol aside it was actually
all it was was a violation was the
offense and
my thought was
perhaps that was one of the reasons why
it wasn't a prosecution
behind
the
hateful spray paint that happened in
nashua that's that's my under that's
just what i was explaining
i understand they hate the issue of the
hate crime side of it but the mere act
of the graffiti
is now would be a class a misdemeanor as
opposed to a violation so that would
cover more than just the mere fact that
it's a hate crime it's not discrediting
or ignoring
the other issue great caused by what
that what happened in nashua i
understand that and i appreciate that
but
the elements of the offense you wouldn't
have to necessarily prove the intent the
intent is that they were
vandalizing public property
spray painting would do that whether
it's a hate symbol or a peace symbol
that's the crime so it does address
some of the concern there where it would
prevent that from happening
it just doesn't directly say it
i'm not saying it solves the problem but
it does address it so you're saying what
happened in nashua wasn't a hate crime
it was just graffiti i did not say that
and and to be to be clear
any behavior relating to that anyone who
does that that that should not be
tolerated by our society and certainly
not accepted by anyone that i know in
this state
then why are we tolerating not allowing
an amendment to move forward to do
housekeeping on this bill
and represent klein knight if you were
inclined to to prepare an amendment what
would your amendment say
i would add the word peoples after
people
or persons
for to insinuate a group of people and
not just
one person
so
so let me just clarify
as opposed to listing
several
classes of individuals
you would just say
terrorize any person or persons
and that's all that's all the amen would
say
i want to indicate the language that a
group of people is still has the right
to be just as protected as one person
yes
it
represent representative you were
recognized
um thank you mr chairman i'm just trying
to make sure that i understand this
correctly um i understand that what
happened in nashua was absolutely
horrible and should not be accepted
we're looking at this and looking at
adding these specific groups of people
so that we can classify this as a
misdemeanor
and
what because that's what's listed as the
penalty in here um the penalty so i'm
just trying to understand how this isn't
covered by what we did um the the action
itself
um would be covered as a misdemeanor
just as we're looking at here um and
and the
i'm just trying i'm just trying to
understand where this gives extra teeth
representative conley
thank you and i apologize to the
representative for shaking my head when
you were speaking but i my understanding
is uh this contemplates a class b felony
does it not
you didn't bring your blue book today
i'll have to review the statute please
forgive me
just give me a moment i'll i can look
into that
representative harry gareth right you're
recognized
if you use a deadly weapon
then it's a felony
other than that it's a misdemeanor
thank you
this is the question representative
calmly what the point i was trying to
make and i'm not sure if i communicated
that well
was that
the prior build that we exact would make
it a class a misdemeanor this is the yes
it's a separate and distinct charge
but it
it's it isn't it would overlap a little
bit there but i guess my question is if
you made it person any person or persons
i didn't read that as i don't interpret
that as already being
an individual
like limiting to one person
that's just my interpretation i i know
representative solemn might have
disagreed with that but i i didn't read
it that way
that it you would have to pluralize
persons in order to apply to a
generalized group
they can be more as written in the law
today they can be more than one victim
of said crime
that's why i'm just trying to i i the
points well taken by representative
clinic
to pluralize it but
is that necessary i just it's a quest
it's just a question i mean
representative sullivan
i guess
this is not just any list of individuals
these are the protected class of people
against discrimination this is not an
accidental list
so
i think it's important to keep
that list of
individuals in here
i can accept the fact that c and d might
not uh be necessary but
in b
this is the list of protected classes of
individuals from discrimination
and i believe having that in here is
meaningful
and important
perhaps i just look at it is that if
if someone were to do any any anything
like this and direct it towards
uh you know just use my race for an
example
i would put that i would just personally
think it would fall into the definition
of terrorize i guess that's where
it's just
representative of our hearn
and at this one we can just
thank you mr chair i mean i know that we
have maybe i'm wrong i can be corrected
but federal law that deals with hate
crimes
number one but two if
if we're going to use
or say this is a hate crime why don't we
just use what's already
covered
under the
hate crime description
i mean
most of it is but some of these things
i'm just marking it there that could
probably be taken out
i think this time we'll just we'll move
the question
if you in support of the motion of linux
being to legislate please say yay
if you're opposed please say nay the
clerk will now call the roll
vice chairman roy
yes representative welch
representative burt
yes representative rhodes
yes
representative greene
clerk votes yes representative testament
representative leon yes
representative pratt
representative marston
yes
representative harriet gathright
representative altschiller
no
representative o'hearn no
representative bordnay no
representative sullivan no
representative newman no
representative bolden
no
representative conley no
representative klein knight
no
representative bradley
chairman abbas
chair votes yes
with a vote of 11 years 10 nays
the bill is ideal
motion passes
would it would it be a majority report
representative roy will be doing the
majority report
will there be a minority report
at this time we'll now close the
executive session on house bill 1117.
at this time we'll now open
the public hearing
on house build 1017
can you hear me all right
yes we can i'm sure there must be
something in the new hampshire criminal
code about bringing a bill to you at
noon
so i apologize and i will try to be as
quick as possible
it's my fault i made the schedule
thank you mr chair and members of the
committee
i am laurel stavis for the record a
member of the house representing the
city of lebanon in grafton county
and i'm honored to come before you today
to present hb 1017
an act establishing criminal penalties
for harming or threatening to harm an
essential worker
as some of you may know i work in a
grocery store
my colleagues and i
consider it a privilege to be on the
front lines making sure our customers
have the food
medicines and other products they and
their families need
we love our work and we pride ourselves
on being a true community supermarket
where many of our customers have become
friends
who care about as much who care about us
as much as we care about them
but in any given week our store is also
a gathering place
for thousands of people
during the pandemic and the hardships it
is presented
people have been stressed sometimes to
the breaking point
i don't have to go into detail
about the incidents of harassment
threatening
assault and even murder that have
occurred in places like grocery stores
and contrary to what you may believe
one of the most frightening incidents i
encountered
came one night from a guest who was
upset that other customers were not
wearing masks
and there was a mask ordinance in
lebanon at the time
it's not often in life that you see a
short wall that divides you from another
person
as a life-saving device
but that night during that customer's
fit of rage i knew that if that wall
hadn't been there i would have been hit
or worse
i've had things shoved in my face
in my eyes
have had to move tearful colleagues away
from situations
where they've been so severely
threatened that their hands are shaking
too much to put groceries in bags
i've seen our store manager call the
local police on several occasions
to escort angry customers on the verge
of violence out of the store
but that's all that can be done at this
point
those customers can and frequently do
come back to repeat the behavior that
got them into trouble in the first place
i've proposed this bill
which amends section 631 of the criminal
code
to give police more options in dealing
with unruly customers patients or guests
in any of the businesses in our state
that are deemed essential
i discussed the reasoning behind the
bill and its potential impact excuse me
with lebanon's chief of police phillip
roberts who supports it strongly and
agrees that it will give his officers
more tools in their toolbox to work with
i also see it as an ounce of prevention
perhaps making people think twice
if they know there may be harsh
consequences for abusing an essential
worker
i have seen some objections on the
grounds that we should not treat these
workers differently from others
that everyone should be equal under the
law
but in new hampshire law we have already
carved out specific penalties for
harming elected officials
law enforcement officers the elderly and
others
clearly the reasoning behind these laws
acknowledged that some
people while equal under the law
are in professions or life situations
that make them more vulnerable than
others
hp 1017 simply seeks
to address the unique vulnerability of
frontline workers who show up day after
day
even though they know it could put them
in harm's way
we've spent the last two and a half
years
thanking essential workers for doing the
work that lets us get on with our lives
despite pandemics constrained supply
lines and any number of other challenges
i hope you will consider an ought to
pass vote
for hb 1017 it will make those gestures
of gratitude really meaningful
under the difficult circumstances many
essential workers and law enforcement
officers manage every day
thank you very much and i'm happy to
take your questions
representative roy you're recognized
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question over here
hi
um
so
my question is
the essential worker
definition
that is an exhibit i understand
only applies during a state of emergency
is it your intent with this statute to
make these essential workers identified
in the governor's order
permanent even if there isn't a state of
emergency
yes
follow-up
you reckon you were recognized for a
and again
i'm going to probably ask almost the
same question but in a different way so
it's your intent that regardless of the
state of emergency or the country if
everything's going smoothly if someone
threatens or or doesn't need things
listed in here against a grocery store
employee or any other person who was
deemed essential by that governor's
order
they should be given this special
protection of this law yeah and and i
think i understand the intent of your
question so let me see if i can try and
address that okay thank you um in in
crafting this bill
i tried hard to arrive at that
definition of essential workers because
it didn't want it to kind of slop over
into everyone right
so um so i used the tool
of the governor's emergency order
as as the thing that
might help this
and bring some clarity to it
but but i was not thinking that well
this means we're in an indefinite state
of emergency it was simply a tool to
help clarify
who under certain circumstances might be
deemed essential workers and i know from
my work in the private sector in private
higher education
that we
have
a group of people that are deemed
essential workers
regardless of the conditions going on
around us you know we could a volcano
could have exploded on the campus and
we'd know who the essential workers were
so that was the tool i had at hand
under the law but i did not intend for
this to be
a perpetuation of a state of emergency
does that answer your question
representative roy you recognize for a
follow-up thank you again mr chairman um
it does with regard to the definition
i'm not i have no quibbling with what
what you used to define an essential
worker
um
my question though is is why
in other words essential workers is kind
of this it's a new concept that was made
by the state of emergency
are you suggesting that in normal times
when there's no state of emergency
these people are are always essential
workers and should always be have the
extra protection or only if another
state of emergency were to become
active where
the essential workers were identified
again
that's a really good question
um
as i said before
in in my life in the private sector
there is a pool of employees that are
deemed essential regardless of what's
going on
i understand that may not be the case at
the state level but it may
because all states have to have chains
of command in response to emergencies
and so there may be a different
definition
that could be brought to bear in an
amendment
um
if it made people more comfortable i was
just looking for a way
to to classify a certain group of people
where the brunt has fallen heavily on
them
and not necessarily because of the
pandemic but just in normal times
representative newman
thank you mr chair
um
when you wrote the bill and did your
research about and referred to the
definition that's in the emergency order
um was there a reason why you
didn't just take the definition that was
in the in that order and put it into the
into the law as the definition of
essential worker for the purposes of
this law
oh i'm so ashamed to say this but i
think it was just laziness so
it seemed it seemed easy to you know to
reference
that order
because to my knowledge and
understanding and you folks have the
expertise that i don't to know this more
than me
that was the only place that
definition that classification existed
if it exists elsewhere
it would be good to know
follow up
um so would you be amenable if that
if there were there were amendments that
were to be made that quoted
the definition that's in the emergency
order
and makes that
the definition of essential worker
for the purposes of this law and the law
i absolutely would be amenable and i was
looking forward to speaking with you
today because i know that you have
the expertise
that that i lack coming from municipal
and county government
just to comment
no one has ever
referred to this committee in that way
before but thank you
representative bert
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
your
testimony i'm looking at this bill
would it allow a
essential worker
to
call the police or file charges you know
i think they'd have to call the police
to file charges
against an employer
against
a government official or a
or the federal government
if they require
an employee
to get the vaccine
and they find it harmful
to their body that they don't want the
vaccine could they use this law if it
was passed
to file against a business or a
company or or the federal government
that mandates the vaccine
i i guess the honest answer is i don't
know it's a really good question though
it's not the intent of the bill
but it's a really good question all
right thank you
thank you representative
thank you very much
okay the committee now calls roscoe
putnam
i've never done this before
so
excuse me if my mouth gets dry
or i lose my thoughts
but i want to tell you a little bit
about myself
my name is roscoe putnam
and when i took a job working at the
listen thrift store in lebanon new
hampshire i never realized that i was
going to become an essential worker
listen provides services to the
community for people that are homeless
hungry
need clothing or just need support
last fall
september 19th
i was working at the listen thrift store
and an unmasked family
came into the thrift store
and i was alerted
by a fellow staff person that we had
unmaskers on the site
the employee approached them
and said you need to wear masks because
there's a mandate in lebanon new
hampshire that all
people in a public place need to be
wearing a mask
it was done professionally it was done
according to our policy
i was then summoned
to talk to the woman
while the gentleman left the building
i approached the woman and i said we
have a mass policy in lebanon
and i would like you to wear a mask
at that point she began to get very
agitated
her agitation quickly turned to
threatening
threatening me and other customers in
the store
i then went to the office called the
lebanon police department and asked them
to respond because i had an unmasked
customer
between the time i made that telephone
call
and
the end of the incident which i'll go
into in a moment
the woman continued to escalate to the
point where people were taking out their
phones and
videoing
her
meltdown
she was throwing things at me
yes they were pieces of jewelry
they weren't harmful
she was threatening me
to take me to court
and she wouldn't leave the premises
i then opened the front door and told
her she needs to leave you need to leave
now
i'd never met this person before i had
no communication with her other than
that day
she at that time said i hope
you have a car accident on the way home
and die
i didn't know what an essential worker
was up until that day
and then i realized that i was there to
protect the public
and my staff i'm an assistant manager at
that store
as i opened the door
there were now
a large amount of staff there
i was telling her to leave
i held the door open and as she went by
me she took my right arm and bit me
she caused three puncture wounds
i ended up having to go to the emergency
department at dartmouth-hitchcock
hospital where i'd have a tetanus shot
and
i returned to work that day
and i returned to work that day because
i felt i needed to continue to protect
the public
and my staff
from anything that may happen from this
she was arrested and she's charged with
four
misdemeanor assault charges
i don't know if that's been resolved yet
i haven't followed through
to follow it because i am continuing to
work at listen community services
i hope you will take this bill
under
advisement
make amendments to make it clear what is
an essential worker and what isn't
and maybe you never thought a thrift
store worker was an essential worker
well i didn't either
but i ask you to support this bill
and give the police
that
the ammunition that they need to protect
the essential workers
from this type of an assault
thank you very much and i'll be glad to
take your questions
thank you for your testimony
we all set
thank you very much thank you again for
your testimony
the committee now calls
russanne chester
thank you for allowing me to speak with
you today
although i completely understand and
empathize with
mr putnam's situation
um and i understand no human
should go through what he went through
whether he's an essential worker or not
and i think that's the bigger thing here
is this is about this is a human rights
thing this is not
this is not an essential worker versus a
non-essential worker
we've already divided our our state and
our people so much that unfortunately
this bill
in my opinion causes further division um
that being said
the appropriate i feel the appropriate
action we have a criminal justice system
that um arrested this individual and is
prosecuting this individual and we have
to rely on our municipalities and our
our lower levels of government to be
able to appropriately
handle those type of situations
the other thing
my concern is is that
we're going to make this bill would make
it a felony
um to
to
to um
my if they threaten
how many of us have heard kids go i'm
gonna kill you
how many of us have heard we you know
we're in the car and someone cuts us off
and we make a threat
this bill well if i'm essential if i'm
if i'm a bus driver
and
the passenger goes what are you trying
to kill me i'm going to kill you
that would
cause a potential for a class b felony
the crime does not
does not fit the does not fit the um
the offense so that's the other part of
this that i have in opposing it
like i said i certainly am not opposed
to um anybody's human rights not to be
attacked because of their beliefs
because of their religion for
discrimination is discrimination it has
nothing to do with masking and unmasking
it has nothing to do with you know
our policy if it's a policy no shirt no
shoes no service that's the policy of
the store if someone wants to get in
your face about that policy then you
take the appropriate action you call the
police and the police will
manage the situation
we have in this pandemic we have created
all these
sheriffs
that are self-patrolling they they've
identified themselves as it's my
responsibility to protect no it's not
it's not your responsibility to protect
it's the responsibility of our
our police departments and our justice
system to serve and protect it is your
responsibility to assist them
but is not your responsibility to
protect
with that being said i am
um
done and i'll take any questions if you
have any
thank you you are you are excused thank
you
at this time we will now adjourn the
public hearing on house bill 1017.
represent overheard you might want to
read the
blue the blue paper for the public
i have
two
in favor and one
against
thank
you
so much
it's a rarity but we don't have another
we have a public hearing schedule for 2
p.m
so
what i would say is we will be the
committee will be in recess to
one 140 145.
and everyone please enjoy your lunch
at this time we will now open the
executive session
on house bill 1017
establishing criminal penalties for
harboring or threatening to harm an
essential worker
this is an executive session
thank you representative burt for
keeping track of accurate time
speaking of representative burke you
wish to be recognized to make a motion
uh hb-1017
i guess i want my mic on
i'll make a motion of itl
that motion has been seconded by
representative rory
representative burke you wish to speak
to your motion yes i would
i look at the bill
and you know it's sad what happened to
the gentleman
you know i don't think anybody should be
put in that position
you know i don't care what side of the
fence you're on
but i just look at it as
you know we have current laws now
and like the gentleman said that was bit
um you know she's facing four
misdemeanors
you know so i think the the law works
but to carve out
you know essential workers and i have a
bunch of nurses in my family my wife
uh kids and um
many nurse friends that my wife has
and they were
looking at this bill saying that they
don't want anything special they just
want to be protected
under current law if something happens
you know because we shouldn't be carving
out different things
you know i know sadly we do in other
areas
and i usually vote against those
so i support the itl and i hope you do
too thank you
at this time the matter will now be put
to question
if you're in support of the motion of
any speeding to legislate please say yay
if you're opposed
please say nay the clerk will not call
the roll
vice chairman roy yes
representative welch yes
representative burt yes representative
rhodes
yes
representative greene yes clark votes
yes representative testament yes
representative leon yes
representative pratt
yes
representative marston
representative harriet gathright
representative altchiller
no
representative o'hearn
representative bordenay
yes
representative sullivan
no
representative newman
yes
representative klein knight
representative bradley
chairman abbas
the chair votes yes
okay 16 years three nays
two not voting
it's immediate
if nobody objects to consent you know
it's only three i think is that the
cutoff or is it two
my understanding that you could it can
be put on consent with three you
representative part you wish to move for
consent yes i think on this bill yes is
there an objection
i object
and would they will they be a minority
report
and there will be a majority
correct
this time we'll now
we now close the executive session on
house bill
at this time we'll now open the public
hearing on house bill 1127.
the is there a member that can
you introduce it
if you just want to introduce it and not
testify you'll be permitted to
is there any member of the public here
to speak
in support or opposition
didn't mean to single anyone out
you
representative conley
thank you mr chairman committee members
as you'll see uh in this bill
it aims to address some historic
injustice with two particular
individuals
the prime sponsor is unable to be here
today
and i believe we can have a healthy
discussion on this during our executive
session
thank you you are excused
to the members on the committee last
term did we have this
same
bill
yes i just
representative newman
i i thought that it was
it talks about historical figures and
whatever and i believe that that was
representative cushing's bill but i
don't remember the outcome but i know
we've seen i thought we've seen this
before
thank you representative klein knight i
was just gonna um ask about the outcome
thank you uh if if it didn't move
forward because of um
kovid or you know for a lot of bills
didn't move forward because of that but
our committee researchers here i'm sure
will be able to
and this time we'll now close the public
hearing
on hb 1127.
representative green
i think it was the last session there
was built either that or something very
similar to it that we had
and i it didn't pass
i know that our committee researcher is
going to
tackle this issue for us
brad do you have that information
there you have it
was that laid on the table with all of
the uh
after coving maybe that might have been
the problem it was in an omnibus bill or
something like that i don't know i
assume it was that
i i just was trying to figure it out but
but it did pass the committee i think is
that correct
okay thank you
at this time we'll now open
the
executive session on house bill
1127.
mr chairman
you have a parliamentary parliamentary
inquiry no i'd like to make a motion
i'd like to move house bill 1 1 2 7
ought to pass
representative walsh number two things
number one uh you have to be recognized
to make a motion two a substitute can't
make a motion
so
just my apologies i thought i was
recognized
point of order
could you just you were recognized for
your point please state your point of
order we
we can you repeat
can you just repeat what the response
was i did that that is
that is not a point of order if i say
something that you do not hear
and you you
at any time anyone on the commit please
ask me to repeat whatever i said
but asking me that's not a point of
order just to clarify a point of order
is when there's a rule
that is not being followed by the chair
of the committee
and therefore you are basically stating
an objection for not following that rule
so that's
not a valid point of order
thank you mr chair may i ask a question
and should i preface it as a
parliamentary inquiry i'm not quite sure
how to be recognized properly
you you have a question you you're
recognized for a parliamentary inquiry
thank you
here's a question could would you please
could you please repeat what your ruling
was on the point of order is that an
appropriate question i did not hear it
in regards to your point of order it was
not a valid point of order because you
were basically said you did not hear
what i said so that is not a point of
vote there's no rule violation that i'm
aware of
and if you can reference one then
that's the ruling
so you're free to challenge the ruling
of the chair but that's the ruling i
made
i have no no intention to
challenge the ruling of the chair all i
want to ask in whatever manner is
appropriate whether you could please
repeat
what you said to the representative when
you were
discussing her motion okay
uh two things
the representative is not recognized to
make a motion number one number two
and specifically a substitute is not
allowed to make a motion or
second the motion so even if i did
recognize the representative to make a
motion which i didn't
it would be out of order for that member
to make a motion
so therefore
which when i acknowledged the
representative i assumed it was for
anything but making a motion
and
that that's it it was that's the ruling
that i made
and we're going to move on from the
discussion
thank you
representative roy
do you wish to be recognized to make a
motion
yes i would uh move
that hp
12 excuse me 11 27 be
found in expedient allegedly
does is there a second
thank you that has been seconded by
representative byrd
do you representative roy do you wish to
speak to your motion
yes just shortly um the the the
preliminary powers of the governor
to pardon even posthumously
exist currently there are also remedies
within the court to have
convictions set aside or reversed
this is not
a legislative act
we shouldn't the legislatures not be
getting into
specific people who we should find not
guilty posthumously
um it it's
it leads us down a road of political
political acts that infringe upon the
executive or the judicial branch these
these
things that are requested in this bill
are already available
to anyone to petition to the governor or
the courts
so therefore i move in expedient to
legislate
representative tessman
uh
just a
question how did it pass
last year
if it
isn't rightfully
something we should have passed
and got laid he got cleared of being
laid on the table
can i ask the committee researcher what
was that bill number again
i don't know what what the roll call was
i don't
i don't have that information with me so
i don't know
how it
it
it did that's that's the record
that it is it passed in the committee or
whatever it did in the community it was
what it was it passed in the house last
term
i think that's a mistake of the clerk
passed on consent last year
which means
oh i'm i'm sorry
last term had passed but according to
the the
the vote that was recorded by
harry gathright representative testman
you and i both apparently support it i'm
just going to say
how can i make a mistake
that's just just that's just that's just
the facts it won't be the first time
there's been a mistake in the recording
but
that's what it says
representative connolly
thanks for making me look that up by the
way
mr chairman committee members i did a
tremendous disservice to the
sponsor of this bill
by not being prepared to discuss it
and for that i'm sorry
so what we just learned is that this
came through this very committee
two years ago
and passed on consent
we know the sponsor of this bill
everyone in this room knows the sponsor
knows how he
the way he comports himself the way he
prepares himself with legislation
what this is clearly trying to do
is a sim
make a symbolic gesture
to address two
uh high-profile
instances uh in which there was a
miscarriage of justice
there are paths where this could be done
currently in law
but
i don't think i think this is quite
clearly meant
to be done as a symbolic move
i believe if it passed this committee
once it should pass again despite
the uh poor introduction and uh
background given a moment ago
can you
and this is a question for this anyone
in the room can you actually an annul a
rest
i thought an annulment was
you can know the the conviction but i
guess
because this this came up on another i'm
just i'm just throwing out there that
when you named two individuals
specifically by name and i'm not saying
that they're not worthy of annulments or
they're not worthy i'm not
taking a position on that
but does the legislator
have the authority for those two and can
we even do are we allowed permitted to
do that i'm just have
representative roy then president pratt
then represented wall
and
thank you mr chairman and i think that
goes directly to my point it's it's a
separation of powers issue if if we if
the court right or wrong in this case
clearly wrong
makes makes a decision
it's upon the court to reverse its
decision not upon the legislature to to
go retroactively and and reverse it so i
that's my point i don't think we have
that power well i think you can annul a
conviction like if you have a conviction
of cannabis
if it's under three possession on the
three quarters of an ounce you can get
the conviction unknown you can do it but
i'm saying this is identifying a
particular person yeah but by the court
not by the legislature you still have to
go into court and do and do it and get
it approved
is an annulment process
so i'm just saying paragraph two and
three i don't know
representative pratt
uh in the case of
eunice uh in 1938
the hampton re-tried that and found him
not guilty found her not guilty
so that was already retrialed and found
not guilty so
i'm not sure exactly what we're doing
it wasn't injustice at the time but they
retried it and found him not guilty at
that time so we're basically reaffirming
what's already been done i guess why
would you do that
representative schiller
somebody else
is this
thank you um first i want to apologize
to the chair i'm sorry i did not
know that rule about making um uh not
being able to make a motion so i
apologize for um upsetting the t-card on
that i know now and i appreciate your
patience um and i also so with regard to
this bill
um
i just want to draw the attention to the
committee that um
the bill is not asking to annul the
arrests of willard uphouse
and eunice goody cole in fact what it is
asked what it is saying
is that the activities
the subversive activities act
that willard uphouse was convicted and
imprisoned on was a manifest injustice
and this act
this bill we are considering
corrects that historical error and
exonerates willard uphouse and annuls
his conviction
and then secondly
the the second part of this
proposal
is that
the legislator finds legislature we find
that the arrest convictions floggings
and imprisonment of eunice goody coal
for witchcraft and familiarity with the
devil
was a manifest injustice and this act
corrects historical error and exonerates
eunice goody cole and annuls her
convictions so we're not asking to annul
anyone's arrest we're asking
representative
cushing
is asking to correct a manifest
injustice and
using
our our power to correct that manifest
injustice and also
annul the convictions of someone who was
tortured
for witchcraft
and also someone who was
imprisoned for
subversive actions so um just want to
correct that we are not
talking about
annulling anyone's arrest that's that's
not an issue
thank you very much
representative pratt
the information you had about the
conviction that was overturned and then
found not guilty
online
it
it's like no official source just online
and then the second one there uh was not
being charged for subversive activities
but was being charged for uh
a year in jail was put in jail for a
year for not turning over records
so that was a crime that was committed
even though um
that was during the cold war the war
between uh the communists and the
capitalism and then the korean war so
the wartime act so
just just
i just wanted to follow on his comment
real quick
just to follow on um furthermore the
conviction
of
of mr up house
was upheld it was a federal charge
upheld by the united states supreme
court
i don't believe the new hampshire
legislature has the ability to
overturn a federal conviction
oh
representative klein knight you were
recognized
thank you chair um
i'm i'm finding it a little troubling
that every
buddy that was on this committee last
year voted for this and not a single
representative voted against it
um
representative
roy what can you tell explain to us what
your first
voting decision of yes was
sure
that was two years ago not one year ago
and i
don't recall voting i don't know if i
was here
and questioning the members of prior
voting records members do have the
ability to change their minds
and i know myself there's been issues
that even this year that i
have changed my mind on
certain things there's a bill that we
vote on in this committee actually where
i voted one way on the house vote i
actually wrote a different way because i
was convinced after the fact so it does
happen i thought for healthy debate we
are allowed to ask why a member has an
opinion on or votes a certain way on
something and the record does show that
um representative roy did vote in favor
of this bill
i i couldn't possibly
tell you what i was thinking at the time
i can just tell you looking at it today
that
what i've already said
stands i really can't speak to what what
i did two years ago what the situation
was
representative marston
thank you mr chairman
i wasn't here two years ago but i'm
understanding that this passed the
committee and was on a consent calendar
therefore did this go to the senate and
get shot down is that
what followed
all right
first of all we're not supposed to refer
to the other
party number one but it my understanding
there was a lot of bills
i can't hear you there was a lot of
bills
that
went to the other body that were not
acted upon
and the mere fact that they were not
acted upon i wouldn't hold that against
the merits of the bill
okay thank you thank you
pandemic so
i wouldn't i wouldn't use that as a
negative one way or another in this just
i understand better now thank you
representative testament
uh just two points
one to representative marston's thing
if you remember remember
we got into a third day
uh that we had a lot of bills left left
undone or not acted on and we just we
tabled them all
that's because of the pandemic
let me just remind you even though we as
a body are remiss and not practicing
there's something in the constitution
called a remonstrance it allows it
allows a person who is wronged or in
this case
probably
do something you know
have a person stand in for him
to come before the general court and we
were we used to be
even though we don't we violate the
constitution we used to be where people
would come saying i have tried
everything else
all these other bodies are not taking
you know not taking heed of me and i
would like you to
abc or d
and that was a legitimate thing
the current speaker and several others
are being sued right now by a
a constituent
for not
upholding those so
you know
we're not practicing it now but there is
a way
for a person to come before the court
and i don't know how you do it but we it
might have been you know this would it
would it wouldn't have been what renny
was doing
we got to refer to him as the our friend
from hampton or the member from hampton
uh i
i guess i'm looking at it if anyone has
been convicted of uh
witchcraft
i mean wouldn't it
i understand that in this situation
involving
um
this particular
person identified in the bill was a
horrible situation but i would say any
person convicted of witchcraft would be
worthy of annulment
which we can do that i'm just saying by
individually identifying a single person
i mean
is his wish
it came to a massive is witchcraft still
a crime under new hampshire law does
anyone know the answer to that
well we wouldn't be able to know a and
not making granted pass law and not
making an annulment for one person you
could do it for
i mean we've done it for cannabis last
term
but
what i'm
no it's not i'm just putting that out
there
representative pratt
not to play this any longer but um
that was a we were part of massachusetts
when that happened it was against the
law in massachusetts
and the area this happened was the area
of land that this happened in hampton
was part of massachusetts at the time i
think this happened
so it was a massachusetts law that was
against the law to be witchcraft i took
practice witchcraft
it's mind me asking the source of that
information i did not know that
representative newman
you're recognized for your parliamentary
inquiry well let me say i have a
parliamentary inquiry again because my
microphone is not on i appreciate the
recognition
and i
i am asking you to clarify for me
about the procedures here i'm not are
we we're i think we're in the voting
mode because we went right to that
without a discussion we've had to
discuss we've been discussing things i
just want to know what what are the
options from here are we still in the
voting mode do we have to take that vote
what
what where how do we proceed thank you
there there is a motion that has been
made has been seconded the question is
um in expedient to legislate and we are
currently not in the voting mode we are
debating
the topic and i would say having a
healthy discussion
doing so so i don't
thank you very much i i misunders i i
did i thought you had called a motion
and i apologize for the parliamentary
representative roy you have a
parliamentary inquiry
something like that
could we possibly um
change this to a concurrent resolution
where we by
resolve that
in the opinion of the legislature this
person
was unjustly convicted without trying to
specifically tamper with historical
records from we have a conviction in
massachusetts another jurisdiction and a
federal conviction or upheld by the
supreme court
i'm not even sure if we can do anything
with that but we could make a concurrent
resolution whereby we expressed that
this was a wrongful conviction
and we the legislature hereby find that
these people
something to that effect
we could certainly do that and that that
would accomplish the goal of
sending the message right
and
is there any appetite to do anything of
that nature
so
we have a
there is a motion
that's been made if it's withdrawn i i
would recess
or i would use to join the executive
session the purpose of today to give you
time to
if if there's enough habitat i don't
want to
could we do a straw poll
question with sure
representative boardney you recognized
uh yes uh can we uh adjourn uh recess
from this
session
with a motion on the floor that we
haven't voted on
the motion would need to be withdrawn
first
so
that's that would that would need to be
done
so whoever made said motion we need to
withdraw said motion
representative rory
i wish you would draw my motion of being
expedient to legislate
so that we might work on another
possible device that
accomplishes the same goal
there you have it
all right well this time i'm now going
to close
we will now close the executives mr
chairman
i think you have to get the second also
oh
representative was that a
point of order that you were trying to
make yes
whoever seconded the motion would they
wish to withdraw that
yes
yep i'll follow uh representative roy
thank you representative burt
at this time we will now close
excuse me we'll recess the executive
session on house bill
1127.
and we will now be adjourned for the
rest of the day
did you just change our minds again
it happens
you